okay here we go
focus car narration okay I get that he's
a race car but he lives in a world where
the cars or living things so why would
racecar has ever spend time in a dark
trailer waiting for some big reveal like
a human world race car are these these
cars taking pictures look does that work
are the helicopters anthropomorphic or
are there cars inside the helicopters
flying them and if these helicopters are
on their own why isn't there a world
full of them having helicopter races
also I see Dinoco still exists in the
living race car world even though this
is a completely different world than the
one in Toy Story if they were a car
outperforming the others like this
especially at the end of the race then
the race wouldn't ever be in question in
other words both and this race this is
no different than a 10,000 meter foot
race right why would an event such as
running be such a big sport in this
world also if every part of these cars
are actual living appendages and need to
be changed periodically like the tires
really starts to make you ponder the
question if I replace all the parts of
an old car is it the same old car or is
it a new car separate men and women's
bathrooms open up the question as to
what makes a car male or female and how
car sex works also shouldn't this sexist
joke about this long line of women cars
be the other way around or am I being
sexist thinking it should be another way
yeah also huh because even female cars
take so much longer in the bathroom men
am i right wait what are these cars even
going to the bathroom for oral changes
top offs this long line makes no sense
Tony Stewart i'm bob cutlass here with
my good friend darrell cartrip get it
it's just like The Flintstones for cars
this race also brings into question why
there are nothing but male cars driving
in it our mail cars inherently faster
than female cars what kind of book does
that contain yards unsportsmanlike
conduct darrell cartrip
would be excellent at cinemasins
this manoeuvre is total bull but this
really is a race like Daytona or
something like that this mega wreck
would cause a delay or a stoppage that
would freeze the action until it got
sorted out wait you're saying everyone
pitted at the 215 mile mark except
McQueen and he's still somehow in the
lead 80 laps later without pitting and
his car hasn't broken down car should
not have tongues but whatever even if
they did the tongue extension should not
count in this automobile race it's
taking them a really long time to figure
out who won this thing
that's a headlight joke right there have
determined that a tiebreaker race
between the three leaders will be held
in California in one week hope you
didn't have plants also why not just
race right now and why is that kind of
take place in California this race shot
off fireworks after announcing a
three-way time I bet the fans were like
you raised some stuck in traffic after
paying big money to see an inconclusive
sporting event this clickin Clarke cameo
is now sad since one of them died
nice going Pixar thanks Obama instead of
a moonroof allowing him to see the stars
this truck has a digital ceiling
allowing him to see the stars while also
wasting a lot more energy sweet somehow
a truck this interesting to the press
will still go missing like moments after
this I get what you're going for here
with the hustle and bustle of life but
it's there any highway in the US with
this much flurry of exits and entrances
going on by the way this car getting
arrived from a truck doesn't endear me
much too late named McQueen but I'm
already having trouble figuring out why
I should root for this guy since he's
been nothing but an asshole since the
movie started The Fast and the courious
this rough-and-tough car street gangs
main motivation is to make tired
vehicles sleep well in order for this
movie to happen it needs the truck to
fall asleep
the asshat neon cars to push the truck
into the rumble strips and the rumble
strips to cause a bobblehead to fall and
open the back door also a hi-tech
racecar transporting big rig would
definitely have a fail-safe in place to
keep lightning from just drifting out
the back of the truck while sleeping
also the tailgate dropping to the
pavement and creating sparks still
doesn't wake up the semi nearly all
these trucks named Mack because if they
aren't that's a bull I don't like it
after driving along thinking every semi
he sees his Mack lightning makes the
crazy decision to pinpoint Mack's
identity to this one exiting semi
because story I mean think about it
lightning why would Mack be getting off
the highway to California and a lonely
exit offering no truck stops or gasoline
or anything the entire movie hinges on
this terrible split-second decision made
by lightning magic train appears so that
this movie has an exciting beat the
train scene that is only in this movie
and no movies before in this world you
can get a ticket for running too fast
electrical and phone wires are not made
out of bungee and neither are the wooden
poles they're attached to so remember
the movie doc Hollywood Michael G Fox
played a doctor who had a big interview
with a plastic surgery office and he had
car trouble and got stuck in a small
town saw Julie Warner's boobs this movie
is doc Hollywood dressed up as an
animated racecar flick and no boobies
unless you count that headlight see
which I don't I'm for a good pun just
like anybody but breaking news as in
news that's so important you break for
it how do we reconcile that this movie
has zero respect for the actual mobility
impact of perking boots you're all aware
of our towns proud history here she goes
again again do you have regular court
sessions in this tiny ass podunk town
enough that she's given this speak
before I don't think so is what I'm
saying
Luigi why do you have it your store
diodes Jesus she didn't even call him to
the stand or anything this is more like
a turf revival meeting than a real court
he's got the horsepower yeah but not the
actual towing capacity if you think of
race car is going to look some giant
Tuareg then you guys are living in a
cartoon to work with best y'all get my
lefty looking at something like that the
whole movie is filled with like this
also in 2006 this was right around the
time you thought man Pixar as a perfect
record made me lose that perpetrator why
cars why after an attempted getaway
lightning runs out of gas at the exact
spot the cop and district attorney
aren't explicably waiting to taught him
Jesus Allah was this fire truck going to
water those flowers and
I just say that they just dart around
this massive road damage as though it's
a puddle paying it no attention
whatsoever thereby kind of proving
lightnings point about how little the
pavement damage really matters Radiator
Springs is filled with the most
desperate salesmen created this side of
Glengarry Glen Ross I also think I now
understand how this town went extinct
extremely old joke about Butte that was
used in Toy Story 2 rears its ugly beaut
in the ass end of another Pixar movie
movie waste time with a lightning
McQueen nightmare where Chick Hicks gets
the Dinoco sponsorship something we
don't get it bout right now because
Lightning has been nothing but a big-ass
hole this whole movie we like chick
better than this dude so it seems like a
good fantasy dose I'm actually wondering
right now why Bessie isn't a
self-contained living vehicle everything
else like this is a living thing why
isn't this and why don't we just have a
little race me and you this guy is super
flexible and applying the law for
spending the first half of the movie
being super stringent about it
wait are those tire tracks in the sky
they have flying vehicles that make
normal smoke right the lap oh let's just
racist by the way a nearly an hour in
and this guy is still a terrible person
you got your tow cable and why wouldn't
he it's attached to him mom ain't seen
you that low in years
I rode like this in you but these cars
really never go anywhere I mean it's the
point of being a car huh that punk
actually did a good job and it makes up
for all the bad stuff he's done so far
if you're going hard enough left you'll
find yourself turning right is he
talking about race cars or sexual
fluidity or city planning there is no
part of this machine stretching out over
this far right foot and a half of road
and yet it's being newly repaved by
magic Porsche tramp stamp with the sitar
machine still running while lightning
sits and talks to everyone shouldn't it
be a pile of unused tar on the road or
is he actually making a speed bump cars
sworn enemy
oh come on
what kind of bolt I'm watching right now
how does this feel let alone this entire
empty ass town require this many goddamn
trackers yes this is rough terrain but
Frank should still not be able to keep
up with or catch up to a fucking race
car he's a combine or a thresher or
something from safe also from this point
forward the much slower mater will
somehow keep up with lightning during
this chase Frank could easily decimate
that fence and keep chasing them except
for the invisible dog fence I'm assuming
is in place here for some reason
wait did something happen in this movie
that would make a love story possible
have they spoken more than 50 words to
each other it's actually insane I'm
watching a Pixar movie right now
it's got so much filler in it when it
came to making this movie I guess they
just threw out that story first
philosophy I know that I made a good
choice you want my best friend movie
makes an attempt at a half-assed
emotional connection an hour into the
movie also this says a lot more about
what a pole Radiator Springs is than any
other attempt by the movie to convince
many this place is a lightning turn all
the way around in this thing wait a
minute
are all the countries the same in this
car world I mean the exact same American
flag was there a Revolutionary War work
George Carr Washington crossed the
Delaware a midnight ride by Paul Revere
a trader by the name of Benedict Arnold
I'd like Sally as much as the next car
but cone-shaped clock cone-shaped lamps
cone-shaped artwork wallpaper baseboards
flower pot picture frame and that's
beyond the huts themselves I think it's
safe to say Sally took the cone theme
way too many steps too far like cheap
might be a serial killer for reals this
asshole dreams this for the third time
and with a third different car winning
all that he wants to win and amazingly
despite the total nothing of the plot
cars is quite long for a Pixar movie
lightning kicks this can which causes a
noise which leads him to investigating
and finding out docs racing past which
makes that the most plot convenient can
that ever existed in a movie trespasser
he has a piston cup three piston cups no
four piston cups aha also could you
possibly land a less likely place to
find a past piston cup winner and your
future wife in a town that has 10 total
cars in it you ever seen him race
you want three piston cops
what news cup my let's take a drive
tractor tipping last night lazy
afternoon drive today it's almost like
lightening wants to follow the script
more than he actually wants to get out
of this town every single daylight hours
should be spent paving that rope but no
he's just blowing it off every chance he
gets
falling in love while racing along
deserted dangerous roads this is a bomb
movie without the humans
okay so Radiator Springs the town is
here the racetrack around Willy's Butte
is here but the farm lands with a dozen
tractors and Frank nowhere to be seen
back then cars came across the country a
whole different way is Jesse about to
sing when she love me because I can
totally come back in three minutes or so
if that's gonna happen also a movie
takes time to give a road history lesson
not so very long James Taylor singing
was fully about the past it literally
doesn't matter what else is going on in
the movie at this point I'm duty-bound
removed once in would happen she just
told you the interstate got built and
redirected traffic Jesus and then the
movie gets way heavy-handed about its
small town businesses killed by the rush
of American commerce and kind of loses
me completely how great would have been
to see this places he did it would have
been the same town only with more
traffic it's kinda nice to slow down
every once in a while sure but you have
a race to win and judging by the sunset
you've just wasted a whole day not doing
the thing you need to do in order to
make it to that race
this tractor tipping thing gets even
more screen time in this zero plot movie
they spend so much time on showing this
turn in the movie there must be one
exactly like it at the Piston Cup track
luckily for lightning he's got someone
who can show him how to do it something
tells me this would have been no issue
at all if lightning made it California's
plan but because he's stuck here
learning his turn suddenly became the
most important thing ever even though
his real problem so far was that he
didn't change his tires and he was a
dick to his crew when I finally got put
together I went back expecting a big
welcome you know what they said you're
history I have never known a time in
sports history when an athlete was still
in his prime and got completely ignored
just because that person suffered a
season-ending injury you probably still
have an owner who would pay for Babe
Ruth to be on their team if they could
afford the exhuming costs this is the
second time I've seen this fire truck
knock over the stack of tires and I have
to wonder why does somebody bother to
continue stacking them back up every
time you were right better than a
Ferrari huh the message of the next
montage is that if you buy a whole bunch
of stuff you were suddenly a good person
it looks like you've helped everybody in
town with one sale each they should be
able to stay in business for 30 more
years or maybe the interstate will
suddenly disappear when did everybody in
town have time to fix all this up
without Sally seeing it and how long did
it take longer than lightning hands to
get to the big race but damned if they
did it anyway
everybody has a dick to lightnings hard
work that took him five weeks holy he
missed the race lightnings been gone for
nearly a week and the damage is done and
the already new Dinoco was wooing chick
but it's suddenly motivated to get that
stupid sponsorship again because his
agent tells him this stuff he already
knows did this Pixar movie really need
Jeremy Pittman doing his entourage agent
if they really made this movie from
spare parts didn't they
pun intended this rush of paparazzi
after Sally leaves makes me wonder how
or why lightning and Sally were ever
allowed that private moment a second ago
in the first place hey are you Doc
Hudson yeah thanks for the call random
media cars seek out the car that tipped
them off so the audience knows who to
blame for this plot development in fact
the country is almost shut down this
country would never shut down or even
almost shut down for a fucking NASCAR
race here's an entire shopping mall that
closed for the race because they want to
fail
I mean shopping malls are losing money
hand over fist so shutting down a whole
Sunday seem self-destructive I am
temporarily distracted enough to notice
that in this arena you can't possibly
have two-way traffic going
- in from seats this has got to be the
most annoying place to watch sporting
events ever flashback fantasy does not
contain a two and a half mile lap dance
doc happy movie a moment aside how does
the last minute unknown pit crew manage
to sneak their way into the infield
without credentials before appearing
suddenly at this piston Cup race doc
took the time to have his old race name
painted on his sides to help the kids in
the viewing audience understand the
importance of self promotion and
braggadocio and at least time
why didn't Sally make the trip to the
race since nearly everybody else did I'm
shaking my head I don't want you to know
my disappointment in this line goes
beyond the verbal into the physical this
is truly a contractual sin against
America and I'm giving it three sins at
once
lightning catches up to the field pretty
easily after being a lap down and
despite that amazing burst of speed will
not zoom past these cars and weenies
aliy and we'll make this dramatic
somehow so remember all that time the
movie spent with that turn finally get
this moment to shine here but one
question how is lightning an expert at
it after failing a million times and
seeing doc do at once also I'm glad
McQueen finally learns and understands
the go heart and a flip you'll find
yourself going right lesson truly I am
but isn't he cheating his ass off by
utterly short cutting miss track by
running through the grass lightening
grows a conscience at the stupidest time
a moment that should show me how much
he's grown actually makes me physically
angry I think the king should finish his
last race something you could have
helped with after winning but whatever
good moral lesson yo fun image but in a
world without humans where cars are
entities all to themselves
why would the infield be filled with
only rvs the RVs are individuals right
camping is a word that should be
basically nothing to the citizens of
this universe right but I didn't win
lightning there's a whole lot more to
racing than just win name one thing
that's racist hey I'm back want to see
my car penis what now happens to
Radiator Springs as someone builds a
Walmart followed by McDonald's and the
charming small town turns into every
other place in the US it took six
writers including a writing team to
write this movie yeah this movie which
for car is normal amount of driving that
has very little to do with any kind of
punishment whatsoever
Disney gives itself ideas for a future
cash-grab remakes whenever this Marvel
thing inevitably crashes and burns
wait a minute here they're just using
the same actor over and over what kind
of a cut-rate production is this Mack is
right about the cut-rate production but
for the wrong reasons Ricky Bobby never
got a sponsoring woody Bush has a huge
sticker on his windshield I think NASCAR
black shaggy like he's sold the
windshield this sticker is dangerous and
inconvenient but I do love it
neo please I have a son Jacob aboard
enosis please watch over him try
and ek brought your kids to your divorce
what's working I feel sorry for them
already laughs yes thank you
or should I say no thank you thank you
for playing should we or should we not
stop Rick cuz Emily was just the same
she was my whole world when somebody
loved me